as game of thrones moved towards its
epic conclusion almost every action shed
new light on something that had been
said before from cryptic prophecies to
long-awaited callbacks here are the
lines that deserve a little extra
attention even the shortest sentences
might have more meaning than you think
Fran's transition from young naive boy
to three-eyed Raven and ruler of the
Kingdoms of Westeros was a plot line
that ran through the entire series from
the first episode to the last as he
became more and more omniscient he
essentially became a totally different
person or non person as the case may be
as each of the stark siblings were
unites with the bran
they gradually figure out that he's
turned the bit well odd neither Sansa no
Arya seemed to be able to make any sense
out of its proclamation that he's the
three-eyed Raven although they do use
his talents to hold little finger
accountable for his crimes in the season
8 premiere Jon Snow finally meets back
up with his long-lost little brother and
sets up one of brands most cryptic lines
of dialogue look at you you're a man
almost in the context of the final
episode Fran's reply here takes on an
entirely different meaning
not only does it indicate that he's not
quite a regular man as that's why I
Draven the almost hints that he still
has a major piece of his destiny to
fulfill being named as the new king why
do you think I came all this way it's
not surprising that Jaime Lannister's
return to Winterfell brings with it some
fairly awkward reunions considering that
the last time he came to visit to the
northern Castle he tried to kill a child
by shoving the poor kid out of a window
as were all well aware though Jaime the
Kingslayer has plenty of other sins
under a spells that go beyond as
long-running affair with his own sister
of course nobody besides bran knows that
Jaime is the man who tried to kill him
all those years ago the things I do for
love
as Jamie stands in front of both the
stark and Targaryen factions at
Winterfell ready to answer for his
crimes he comes face-to-face with bran
himself he seems to be sealing himself
for the moment where brand reveals one
of Jamie's worst moments but that
revelation never comes instead that bran
simply echoes Jamie's exact words from
the moments where Jamie pushed him out
of that tower the things we do for love
this ultimately lets Jamie know that the
spike runs long journey to become the
three-eyed Raven a being who seems
beyond concepts like revenge and
forgiveness he'll never forget what
Jamie once did to him one of the seasons
most heartbreaking moments comes right
after the assault on Daenerys enough
fleet after losing one of her dragons
ray ghoul to one of Coburn's scorpion
spear launchers your ships are attacked
by your own Greyjoy in the skirmish
Masson day he was long beam when of
Daenerys his most trusted advisors is
kidnapped by Greyjoy soldiers tragically
misunderstood can prove a twisted point
to the nearest offered the opportunity
to speak our last words
Hassan day gives her final response
funds are thrown to recognize this as a
command Daenerys uses to make her
dragons breathe fire on her enemies but
it means even more to miss on day the
first time she ever saw the nervous use
it the mother of dragons employed it
against the slave who once owned an
abused Masson day which ultimately freed
her dracarys
even though miss and Akon directly
Unleashed dragon fire with their last
words it's one last reminder of how much
Daenerys has given her and how much
power and love Daenerys inspires in her
subjects as well as the burning rage as
Cersei has now unleashed Jaime and
Cersei Lannister rapini inextricably
linked often physically since a very
beginning of the show even after the
show's seventh season when Jaime left
her sister behind after she threatened
to kill him viewers knew that their
destinies were still intertwined and the
only question was how still it might
have been a little surprising when after
years of character development and a
slow burn romance Jamie left Brienne and
his northern allies behind to rejoin his
twin slash lover after a fight to the
death with Joran he store returns to his
true love and queen in a last-ditch
attempt to escape when the two find that
paths entirely blocked as a sealing
begins to cave in above them Jaime says
something that explains all of his
actions
nothing else matters since the beginning
these two have stuck together and as
Jamie told Brienne back in Winterfell
almost every evil act he committed was
in service to her but Jamie a few years
have played the role of a good guy just
son enough to erase those sins to him
the only thing real is his relationship
with Cersei and they deserve to die
together after a victory at King's
Landing Daenerys disappears for a few
victory laps on drogon the dragon before
returning to a newly conquered city
landing at the ruins of the red keep
Daenerys addresses her and sullied in
Dothraki Army giving off distinctly
tyrannical vibes as she informs her
troops that their war is far from over
it's tempting the thing that the narrows
would be satisfied in their quest for
world domination now that she has killed
her rival queen and taken the capital
city
she's even giving the speech while
standing above Circe's body burrowed in
the rubble beneath ax instead she asks
our armies to join her in liberating
every person in Westeros the speech is
made to an overwhelming roar but at this
point the only wheel left to break is
the one of conquest that Danny's going
to roll across the continent Daenerys
has always pledged to rid the world of
injustice but in her quest for total
control of every inch of the Seven
Kingdoms it becomes frightened Leah
Perrin that she's more power hungry than
anyone anticipated after resigning from
his position as hand of the Queen due to
Daenerys slaughtering a city that had
already surrendered Tyrion is taken into
captivity to await his fate which will
most likely come in the form of being
roasted by dragon fire
just like his pal Varys while in
captivity Tyrion is visited by Jon Snow
who was equally troubled by Daenerys
decision to kill thousands of innocents
in King's Landing
John initially insists he's still firmly
on her side but over the course of the
conversation Tyrians bluntness seems to
get through there's an especially
crucial moment when Tyrion offers up a
reminder that it's not just John's life
us in danger since he's the actual true
heir about his rebellious sister Sansa
probably won't last long against a
conquering dragon queen either it was
all well and good when Daenerys was
destroying slavers captors and other
evil men
but now she's hell-bent on destroying
anybody in her path whether or not they
truly deserve to die
when Tyrion tells John that love often
overcomes reason Jon offers up a
memorable proverb in respond
love is the death of duty you just came
up with that the line actually came from
Maester Aemon Targaryen with whom John
spent time during his first stint of the
Nights Watch at Castle black
Tyrion however has an equally sage
response sometimes Duty is the death of
love with that lion aterial needs John
to as inevitable fate and the
realization that John was killed an
heiress to protect Westeros but fat John
leaves to give Danny one last chance to
step back from the edge of world
conquering madness and when she doesn't
he does his duty at last in a pretty
great twist of fate all three surviving
stark children end up right where it
seemed that they wanted to be bagged her
in the first episode Sansa is a
beautiful Queen that she always
fantasized about becoming John is off to
join the Nights Watch again and Arya has
become the skilled fearsome adventurer
she always wanted to be drawing the
tearful goodbye between them John even
insists her Arya's welcome to come visit
him up north
Castle black might technically forbid
women from entering its gates but John
is pretty realistic about the fact that
nobody would be able to stop her however
the younger of the stark women tells him
she won't be able to visit she has other
plans I'm not going back north
[Music]
what's west of Westeros it's
unsurprising that Arya is already
planning her escape from Westeros ever
since her time exploring Braavos she's
been hard to pin down and now that the
realm is safe in the hands of her
brother it's about time for our next
adventure there's a whole unknown world
out there for her to explore after
saying of farewells to her sister and
brothers that's where she heads in the
episodes closing shards to view a sea
Aria one last time gathering her weapons
and arranging Maps before proudly
strolling along a crunch ship which
turns out to be a dawn to the symbols of
House Stark no matter where she goes
she'll always have Winterfell with her
some well Tolly was never a great
fighter but since he managed to defy all
the odds and fan expectations to survive
to the final episode of the series it
was clear that he would have a huge role
to play during the ending of Game of
Thrones a bookish and somewhat sheepish
figure from the time he did enough
research on greyscale to huge awe a
moment's affliction to the time he
helped bran confirm Jon's true heritage
as Aegon Targaryen this all comes to a
head during the series finale when Sam
addressed in the white robes of a
maester and the part of Tyrion small
council presents the hand of the king
with an enormous book written by the
archmaester with whom Sam worked whether
for Citadel confirming a long-held fan
theory that Sam would ride to released
help write the history of Westeros since
Robert's rebellion some reveals that the
name of the tome is a Song of Ice and
Fire
I helped him with the title this is of
course the same title that author george
RR martin gave to the series of books on
which Game of Thrones was based as a
survivor of all eight seasons Sam was
present for many of the major events of
the series so if he was meant to play
the role of a stand-in for Martin that
seems like a perfectly fitting end for
his character maybe he'll be the one to
finally finish writing the winds of
winter and the dream of spring with all
of our usual suspects for who would sit
on the Iron Throne either dead or
imprisoned and the throne itself melted
into slag the time comes for the
remaining cast members to choose a new
leader of Westeros that's when Tyrion is
brought before a new council led by the
last remaining members of the Seven
Kingdoms great houses including Yara
Greyjoy the entire stark family and
unnamed Dornish Prince and long-lost
faces like Robin Arryn and Abner Tully
who gets dunked on so viciously that he
might never recover and I must miss it
Tyrion is nominally there to stand trial
for betraying the Queen so it seems
unlikely that
the Chancellor suggests the next ruler
of Westeros himself as usual however
he's full of surprises asked if he would
like to roll he says that he doesn't
want it but having had some time to mull
it's over he's made up his mind about
the best candidate and he reached his
conclusion for a pretty surprising
reason he tells the assembled Nobles
that stories are the most powerful
things on the world and then makes this
endorsement and who has a better story
and brand the broken by suggesting bran
Stark is a next king of Westeros as well
as suggesting that all future rulers
should be chosen by a council rather
than simply born into their title Tyrion
finally breaks the wheel Daenerys fought
so hard to destroy introducing a more
merit-based system of monarchy into the
Seven Kingdoms you've had a strange
journey stranger than most perhaps
surprisingly everyone assembled agrees
deciding that bran does in fact have the
best story certainly better than John a
secret king who literally came back from
the dead to ride a dragon into battle
against an army of zombies and
tragically killaz and slash lover or
arya who became a faceless assassin got
revenge for a family's death by taking
out an entire noble house and saved the
entire world by straight-up shanking the
night king maybe Westeros has a
different idea of what makes for a good
story than we do check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]